what is amazing about the office fans
is
and i and i have said and it is true
like the best gift that i have been
given from the show is truly
how
being able to experience from the inside
how much the show means to people i mean
like truly
means to people and
and it's bizarre because i i try to
think of myself
and
and and translate
their love for the show in me for
something else
and it's hard for me to find but what i
what i'm talking about is like people's
desire
and and need to tell me
how much the show has meant to them how
much the show meant to them
in a really
dark time in their lives yeah that the
show brought them comfort that brought
them made them feel better
um healed them in some ways and i mean
you know military veterans or people who
have the same thing yeah gone through
an incredible loss in their life or a
medical condition and and that they want
to tell the story
and so do i like it i mean it's
draining it's very dry it's very
draining it's amazing but it's also like
when everybody's doing it you're like
you want to give them the attention you
want to give them the love and you're
just like oh my god i'm just i'm so
exhausted exactly and and i know that
that sounds like ho poor you having to
sit there and listen to people
i know it's crazy but like that because
that was an office convention right
i think it was slated to go from nine to
six that's yeah and i
didn't
take a lunch break
i didn't i did not leave
because of the people waiting times
i was there until about 8 15. yeah
i think it's a it's a beautiful thing
when you connect with someone and they
tell you what the show meant to them and
you you know you're surprised you're
like how could this
something that was just funny and goofy
and we had fun i was getting paid for it
how could this mean so much to you
but then when you you try to wrap your
head around it it's kind of it's a
little confusing but it's also a
beautiful thing and what i meant to say
is not that it's like you get drained
it's just like
you know you do a podcast for an hour
right you don't want to talk anymore
right right i don't want to do more than
an hour with you
it will not go over an hour right so
imagine you're there for
nine hours of talking to people right
it's just naturally you're going to be
exhausted right
right yeah so it's but i it is
um
it does mean a lot to me sure it really
it really does and i think that
specifically
the show in a lot of ways how it was
constructed
um you know i've talked a lot about this
on my podcast
when i talked to
the other cast members that i sat down
with one of the questions that i asked
everybody was about the last line of the
show
and what that meant to them and clearly
greg daniels the creator wrote the last
episode so he wrote the last line and
the last line goes something like
um
why did they decide to do a documentary
about a paper company
well i think it's a great subject it's
about beauty in ordinary things
isn't that kind of the point
and i think that that celebration
of the ordinary for the office
that cell that
these people have meaning we spoiler
alert we weren't like friends right like
we weren't like on the cover of cosmo
and doing all of the glamorous stuff i'm
talking about the actors too who were on
the show right we were a
group of ordinary people who were
assembled by a great casting director to
work together in this place and
and that celebration i think is what
what responds to people